attention Dune fans our time is fast
approaching Dune part two hits theaters
on March 1st I don't I don't believe you
in the meantime there's been plenty
going on behind the scenes to get us
hyped from Jason mima's stunts to plenty
more sandworms we've got all the inside
details you've been dying to know about
this highly anticipated sequel one of
the best parts of the Dune franchise the
VFX and cinematography plenty of movie
Magic went into making this movie what
it is and that's where some seriously
good VFX comes in VFX head Paul Lambert
had plenty of work to do Lambert prefers
practical effects when possible and he
also needs a good base from the actors
in order to apply VFX to the best cuts
possible you then have the best that you
could have possibly caught which then
makes a far better visual effect so
while there aren't actors playing those
sandw worms they did have a bit to do
with how great they look and if you're
thinking that the visuals couldn't
possibly compare to to Dune part one
think again as director Deni villanu
says they had just much more fun with
cema in a way it's like it would be more
cinematic I think and it surely doesn't
hurt that the entire movie was shot on
IMAX cameras which was only the case for
half of the first installment another
standout aspect of Dune part one was its
incredible cast so of course many of
those actors's return for the sequel was
of the utmost importance for this film's
success Timothy is returning as Paul
atres the film's protagonist do you
believe in me and among others Zena will
be returning as well plus she'll be
featured much more heavily in the second
movie than she was in the first and this
amazing cast is only getting bigger and
more star studded the second time around
Florence Pew will be playing princess
ilon Corino Austin Butler will be taking
on the role of fade rala harinen who was
famously played by Sting in the 1984
film adaptation Christopher Walkin joins
the cast as Emperor shotam IV and Leia
sedu joins as lady Margot with an even
more famous cast and in the wake of the
success of the first film it's safe to
say that these cast members may have
some good news come award season
unfortunately that will have to be next
award season thanks to 2023 Hollywood
strikes the strikes caused a major delay
for Dune part two ultimately moving its
release date from November 2023 to March
2024 it's easy to see that this cast
didn't just join this film in hopes of
some accolades come award season they
also seem to thoroughly enjoy their
fellow cast and crew members and the
meshing between the returning and new
cast members were no exception to this
Austin Butler joined the cast this time
around and working with co-star Timothy
shalam was a highlight for him we bonded
immediately I really love him a lot and
uh I've been a huge fan of his work in
fact this cast was close enough that
shalam was even happy to bring his dad
to set when the movie wrapped filming
the actor posted a selfie of him with
his father in the desert where they
filmed captioned desert dad speaking of
the desert Dune part two certainly won't
be short on Amazing visuals and the
setting is an important part just like
in the first movie the desert is a
character of its own and Zena showed
just how important this character is
with this Instagram post showing the
desert and signing off with love from
Arcus despite how beautiful this filming
location is it wasn't an easy place to
shoot gets so hot during the day that
sometimes you have to shoot between 5:00
a.m. and 7: a.m. and 5:00 p.m. and 7:00
p.m. because would be too dangerous to
be shooting outside especially with the
kind of still suits we were wearing but
the hot desert wasn't the only place
they filmed they also headed to Italy to
take advantage of the Bon tomb which
provided beautiful architecture for the
film of course not all of the set was
ready made and because Deni venu prefers
to cut no corners he made every single
set piece from scratch yep even the ones
that they could have reused from the
first movie in addition to the set just
like in Dune part 1 Dune part two
required some seriously impressive
costume design to make the unique world
and characters really come to life
before our eyes every single little
thing had to be designed with the
complexity and style makeup artist
Donald moet's Vision had a lot to do
with making this style work gave us an
opportunity to do a practical makeup
that we had the luxury of time and you
know some budget to be able to do and
from the looks of the trailer the hair
and makeup Department really hit it out
of the park this time around we could
barely even recognize Austin Butler what
do you think Dune part 2 has in store
will it be better than the first let us
know in the comments and for more videos
like this one like And subscribe to the
things